[Musique]
pensez vous qu'il dit on va parler
aujourd'hui de la fête de la musique
j'ai essayé de comprendre casser la
figure c'est cette année la 38e édition
oui oui vous en pensez quoi d'ailleurs
de cet événement on va donner cette
tablette à léonie de clermont ferrand
bonjour bonjour la tablette les
questions et b la fête de la musique ça
vous inspire quoi
en bon moment qu'on passe suisse avec
ses amis de l'amusement la fiesta
s'écoule par ans promène on écoute de la
musique et des fois on joue on chante
j'imagine plus des soirées à déambuler
dans des rues à écouter différentes
musiques à passer cela différents
barreaux c'est quand même une fête
importante j'ai l'habitude d'y avec mes
copines et tu vois là depuis longtemps
oui les puits des trois ans moi je viens
d'un petit village tu prouves et bah
c'est pas du tout la même ambiance que
dans les plus grandes villes
ragon de l'eau à paris et tout c'est
beaucoup plus convivial on reste avec
les voisins tout ça et on passe dans les
rues dans les petites rues on écoute
belgique
de quel village bracieux sévère chambord
il a créé depuis quand existe elle à
jacques lang enclos dès 1990 bravo ça a
été créé par jack lang en tout cas et
donc tu sais qu'il a beaucoup oeuvré
dans la région aussi et voilà
etes-vous mélomanes ou musiciens je joue
de la guitare et du piano et j'ai déjà
chanté pour la fête de la musique à
blois tours où il faudrait tout venir
on pourrait croire
il faudrait tout oublié je joue du piano
en autodidacte depuis deux ans voilà je
fais un peu de piano et je chante
parfois et déjà mis mais c'est pas
quelque chose de sérieux c'est vraiment
pour ses pas pour s'amuser
bonjour
puis là j'ai toujours eu ce bonheur
si je l'aurais je joue diverses musiques
qui me plaisent ça peut être du pirate
des caraïbes dû à la noix au coeur
est-ce que là alors on pense pas ou il
ya un air de musique qui te passe par la
tête
sapé comme jeanne et ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta coco
deschanel lamah maïga et el hadj aux
chaussettes sales les cela que chanter
s'il te faire
ballon sans quoi elle veut toute façon
mais j'ai comme elle veut connaître mes
secrets lui c'est plus la suite
bravo
[Musique]